HINOSTROZA.
FLAMES DO NOT GIVE YOU A LOT OF
DOWN SOME CORNER.
TAGE THOMPSON DOWN INTO THE LEFT
CORNER SO THE SABRES ARE WORKING
INTO TIGHT CORNERS AND BELOW TH
PLAYED AROUND A
TOKARSKI.
COOL AS A CUCUMBER FOR AS MUCH
AS HE BATTLES BACK THERE FOR TH
GAME OUT HERE, THEHERE FOR SKINR
AS HE HAD BUFFALO ZONE.
GAUDREAU TRYING TO GET THAT INTO
THE SLOT AND A COUPLE OF
MILAN LUCIC COMING DOWN THE WING
HELP.
KEEPS IT SIMPLE AND THROWS IT TO
THE NET.
TOKARSKI IS ABLE TO MAKE THE   .
FLAMES PARTIAL BREAK.
GOALTENDER FRIENDS AND FAMILY I
THE C IT BACK TO PITCH-OUT
ACROSSOARDS AND PYSYK WILL
KEEP IT N.SENDS IT ALONG THE SA.
WELL, THIS IS WHERESHING BACK A.
YOU'VE GOT ONE MAN TIED UP IN
FRONT.
ADVANTAGE.
PLAYS IT TO THE WING.
PASS ACROSS AND HE S UITE
FIGURE OUT WHERE IT WAS.
MANGIAPA RIGHT THERE.
BACKLUND JUST REACHES AROUND
HERE AND SLIDES IT ACROSS TO AS
SAY, HE'S DONE A LOT, BUT HE'S
MONAHAN TO TKACHUCK.
LOOK AT THAT PASS.
STRAIG LINE AND ASPLUND KICKS
IT UP
SEASON.
THEY HUNG HIM UP TO DRY IN THAT
SECOND PERIOD AND THIS IS JUST N
THE THIRD PERIOD HERE.
FLAMES WILL B BOARD.
A QUIZ  PLACE  NOT SURE WHERE I
IS.
KEEPS DOER. WELL, IF HE WANTS S
KYLINGTON.
HERE'S A ARS IN HIS CAREER TO G.
>> Dan: S SEE TO HAVE SUCCESS.
JOHN HAYDEN WHO IS OUT